this can be a great experience looking
forward to it Ryan and the team at the
ink factory come up with we're going to
start is this is about how do we help
you reach peak performance via coaching
that you receive as well as coaching
that you're going to give to your team
so this will be a fast-paced moving
around talking about best practices and
coaching ideas to try and the ability to
put this into action so you can see real
quick this is the business that I run
its voltage leadership consulting you
can see we do some various activities
and you know I'm really excited to be
here with you today having been in the
lab industry working with you many of
you across the country and many of you
across the world reposted workshops
anywhere from roanoke to abu dhabi as
you can see here i'm getting coached
some from my friend Omar we're getting
ready to go dune bashing right outside
Abu Dhabi some of you ray may recognize
it from the recent Star Wars movie this
is where they filmed a lot of the star
wars and I'm going to be coached on how
to jump over those major hills and I am
honestly a little scared there but
luckily Omar is a great coach and
teaching me how to do it but first we
had to have some hands-on coaching as
you can see here so Omar had to get the
camels off road so we could get there
some of you I'm sure feel this way when
you're trying to lead your team it can
feel like leading a herd of camels we're
going to give you a few ideas on the
best way to motivate and engage your
team today but it has been a great
experience working with Cleveland Clinic
Abu Dhabi they've just opened a new
hospital there we were able to do a
serving leader program and get to teach
coaching and leadership skills in a new
part of the world and they have 3,300
people now trained and operating in Abu
Dhabi so let's start with you now why
should I trust you this is a great
question one of things that may keep you
from training and coaching your team
right now is there's a gap between what
your folks feel and how much they are
trusting you with their career with
their ideas with their dreams hopes and
aspirations so why should the people
that you
trust you do you trust your leader if so
why are why not another question I might
have for you is why are you not coaching
your team right now many of you I know
the first answer is going to be time I
know how busy are I've worked in the
labs I see you guys understand the
challenges do more with less go faster
here we got new certifications we get
done there's a you know Joint Commission
coming in or cap is coming in for
inspection but if you're not coaching
right now somebody is looking to take
your talent they're going to need it in
their organization and so coaching will
allow you to be able to connect with
your team keep them motivated and
engaged my other question for you is why
are you not getting coached it's good
enough for athletes piano players
artists singers all get coached why do
we not take the time to get coached so a
lot of times it will come down to this
issue of trust am I ready to trust you
with my career my hopes my dreams my
concerns so who do you trust well for
some they trust Fox News that's where
they go to get their information what
are the people that are in your team go
to get their information in our house we
trust fox news for things like the
debates my kids think of them for things
like American Idol football and back in
the old days for me maybe 24 how about
CNN who trust CNN for me I always think
back to early days of CNN and their war
coverage in 1991 I also travel a lot
internationally and so for me a lot of
times it's going to be that
international traveler CNN is that place
where I can go and feel like I've gotten
real good information about the United
States who do you trust it could be your
boss maybe you trust Warren Buffett for
your financial advice maybe it's Oprah
Winfrey for influence maybe it is a
leader in your community maybe it's a
former boss but at some point you've
trucked to somebody with your hopes and
dreams with your desires that's a start
for coaching relationship
is trust and so I really want you to
think about who do you trust and why do
you trust them the first resource that
I'm going to offer to you is a book
called thanks for the feedback the
science and art of receiving feedback
well this is from a Doug stone and
Sheila hon you may recognize Doug stone
from the book difficult conversation and
what they talk about in the book is that
feedback is really three different
things with different person purposes
the first is appreciation this is about
how do you motivate and encourage the
second is coaching this helps increase
knowledge skill capabilities it will
help you grow and it raises good
feelings in the relationships the third
is evaluation evaluation is telling you
where do you stand aligning expectations
and making sure that you are able to
make good decisions and know where your
decision-making is allowed to go so
again it's the ACE model appreciation
coaching and evaluation will cover in
some more detail as we as we go
throughout the presentation what I want
you to understand though is that
evaluation as you can imagine that's the
one with the loudest voice it can drown
out the other two and so we always can
understand that part of our job as
leaders is to give evaluation and we are
supposed to be there to help our team
understand holiday performing and that's
a valuable resource because before I can
really be coached I have to know how I'm
doing what matters though is what is
your mindset as you go into the coaching
are you going into coaching thinking I'm
going to correct the people that work
for me I'm going to make sure that they
know what they're doing is wrong if
you're going into a relationship a
conversation with that kind of attitude
then you're probably going to get a lot
of defensive pneus and the coaching is
not going to work very well so what we
talked about trying to encourage you
with coaching is instead of that's wrong
shift to an attitude of sharing what
you're seeing but
them to say tell me more about how I can
get better so maybe the question should
be here's what I'm seeing tell me about
when you've been your best what can I do
as your leader to help you be at your
best more consistently so really it's
about having the right conversation with
the right people at the right time and
the right intent will play with that
concept a little bit more in a couple
slides moving on this first model of the
day and so this is how do you really
understand peak performance and getting
the most out of your high potential
people that are on your staff and gang
that's everybody everybody that you hire
has potential and you've got the ability
to grow and develop them and I want you
to think back to when you hire them
you're so excited about the potential of
this person joining the organization in
the first 30 or 60 days you stayed so
connected with them you were helping
them understand expectations you
probably recognize their efforts some
you may be in gave them feedback and
refine their performance but then you
get busy they get busy and sometimes we
slip and so what we're asking you to
think about is when you've got someone
on your team have you done all of these
so let's go through the model in a
little more detail will be referring
back to small throughout the breast of
the presentation so next our goal is to
have motivate and engage employees as I
travel around the US speaking I hear
this all the time Jeff my folks just
don't seem to be that motivated how do
you deal with a person who doesn't seem
to be motivated how do I make sure that
they say motivate how do I make sure
that they stay with our company how can
i get my engagement scores up well let's
look at this slot at the bottom is
really where we need to start and it's
how do I work so what we're looking for
are where are the goals from our role
where the tools that need to do the job
what are the things that matter do I
understand that if I don't understand
that it's really hard for me to
understand and buy into your vision once
I understand that concert
quinces understand the goals then I can
perform for you if you move to the next
level you can see it as the motivation
engagement starts to get better once I
know my goals and move up if someone
recognizing me are you giving me praise
do you give me the opportunity to try
some new things does it seem like you
care if I start to see that then I'm
ready for feedback from you because I
know you care about me I know you care
about me doing a good job and I'm ready
to succeed further how do I contribute
do I have influence around what we do
around here it might allow some
ownership so many of the labs I work
with they're now doing lean and 5s
events and what the benefit of that is
is we go when we ask employees what is
it that we can do around here to make
our organization run more smoothly and
we ask for their input and so at the end
of a day where we've done 5s and had a
lean intervention the employees came up
with the solutions get the buy-in get it
implement it and start using a new
process the very next day in the lab
they go back to the bench excited and
the reasons that is they saw that they
had some ownership some say and they're
able to build relationships with peers
that they couldn't have done before that
when you're able to do that the
organization moves forward and now I am
ready to grow with you so when you ask
me about what it is that my career goals
are if I'm thinking about going into a
management role I'm going to look and
say have you built trust with me through
these other levels have you give me
clear goals you recognize me have you
love me had a chance to contribute and
now I'm ready to work with you and to
really be coached a quick story from my
own experience and I was a leader at
Capital One and one of the things that
happened was a door need to be fixed the
CEO was coming to the company to do a
town hall and I feel so excited about
you know we've got about 2,000 2,500
poise I'm responsible for and the CEO is
taken time out of his day to come to us
the week before we've been on business
week magazines front cover about one of
the most exciting places to work so I've
got everyone prepped I've shared the
vision here's
we're going to do and there's going to
be all kind of growth and excitement for
you wait till you hear from rich and so
it gives a lovely presentation and he
opens it up like I will do at the end to
some questions and the very first
question that they asked was when can we
get the door fixed I was like mortified
I'm like oh my gosh he went on he
answered the question and we had a
conversation afterwards I found him and
just said rich and I'm really sorry
about that he goes Jeff this is a great
leadership opportunity for you if you
can get the door fix they'll buy into
your vision but it's the little things
that matter and so think about the lab
do you have good benches do they have
the equipment's that they need for some
that were scrubs do they like their
scrubs the first time we went into one
of our labs that we had acquired that
was the first thing they asked for they
said we don't like the color the scrubs
so before they bought the vision that we
were sharing they need to know that we
cared about them so go to the bottom and
do you help them understand their roles
and then start to move up that's the
basis of coaching relationship so what's
my role where do I fit in again give me
clear expectations give me the resources
do my job and help me understand how I
fit into the culture because I want to
do a good job around here I need to know
what matters so make sure you still in
from me what matters what you care about
where they keep the Hagar's I want to do
the behaviors for you but I gotta know
what you care about and I got to see you
role model them if I see you role model
them then I know how to fit in and know
how to make a difference here next make
sure i know my authority what are my
responsibilities what decisions can i
make i will tell you that there is an
excellent book out there that if you
need some help setting some clear goals
and being able to really help get down
to specific expectations it's book
called winning with accountability I'll
repeat that winning with accountability
and it's a great tool for setting
expectations getting employees to
understand what they need to do and
being able to have clear understanding
of the goals and how to reward the goals
so again winning with accountability by
Henry Evans
so my final fall in this slide would be
resistance is often just a lack of
clarity resistance is just a lack of
clarity and so if you're seeing
resistance the first time instead of you
thinking that that's a limb problem I
would have you look and say have I given
them clear expectations have I given the
tools to know how do the job if i sat
down with them and really explain what
matters around here how we're going to
measure how are they going to be
assessed at the end of the year into the
quarter end of the week until I know
that I may wait because I don't want to
mess something up and so if you're
seeing some resistance try to go back to
some clear expectations ultimately if
you give them clear expectations and
then there's resistance we'll talk about
some ways that we can overcome that
later in the presentation the next part
is do you appreciate me if you can see
on the slide here the brain is lighting
up this is an actual brain and showing
the parts of the brain when I get
recognized how it lights up I call it
lighting up the Christmas tree we all
have folks that you know when you've
given them the compliment you can just
see them excitement and enjoy that they
have one of my daughters you know she
will blush so all feedback is a gift but
it's not a gift it's either is easily
received no matter we whether we fight
it or we blush or warm up all feedback
will be stuff that will have an impact
on us whether it's our brain our body
but you know we really do like to get
positive recognition what's the right
amount you may be asking up to one ratio
is the right amount so 5s for every
negative comment unfortunately most
organizations are at a one-to-one so
it's one positive statement for every
negative statement unfortunately in
health care many of our organizations
are at two negative for every positive
so again the ratio is 5 positive for one
negative some of you may be saying gosh
up that seems really planning a
Pollyanna SH people do make mistakes ask
lutely and here's the deal we're good at
recognizing those we have a hard time
taking a moment to be able to recognize
folks and I get it a lot of your busy
and may not have a time you feel like so
a couple tips one be authentic don't
kill my feedback on just something like
okay wow I really appreciate that you
moved X to Y when that's just something
really basic no really be authentic set
up a plan maybe it's an Excel
spreadsheet where you go in and say how
much feedback have you given to each
person this week put some time on your
calendar to walk around the lab and it
give positive feedback you can give
corrective feedback at the same time but
be really intentional another idea is
have your people whether it's your
direct reports your technicians or your
supervisors send you an email each week
saying something positive that's
happened on your team it gives you a
great chance to be able to walk out of
your area go to the lab and be able to
say thanks for something that's gone
well it will do amazing amount for your
motivation engagement another resource
to check out they've got some videos on
YouTube as well as a book is called the
carrot principal again it's the carrot
principal and basically their feedback
says that people say that sixty-four
percent of the people surveyed said they
had not been had a positive recognition
in the past year now I probably did
happen that they had the recognition but
they're feeling was they had not been
recognized throughout the past year
probably because there was so much
negative recognition did it drown the
positive so again five positive for
every negative put it on the calendar
pull up on the bench and sit next to
someone and give some feedback next this
moves into the evaluation phase would
you review with me what's going right
what have I done correctly and what do I
need to do differently another great way
of asking this is are the things I need
to start doing stop doing and continue
really be specific and I would tell you
have to
courage to be direct too many leaders I
work with especially in health care we
like to really take care of folks in
healthcare want to kind of water it down
the more direct you can be in and being
honest with them the better the chance
now that doesn't mean be mean that's
being direct and be able to share the
feedback in a direct manner so that your
intent is to build them up not tear them
down but by being direct they know
exactly what they need to do a great
question to to talk to the person about
is here's what I see you're doing really
well and the more often you can do this
the better we will be then asking them
how is it you can do your best work on a
more regular basis how can you do your
best work on a more regular basis see
what they come up with and it didn't
build from that move into the next slide
which type of feedback do you provide
more often so there's three types
appreciation evaluation and coaching in
evaluation and coaching what we find is
that many of our leaders they spend so
much time in evaluation that we never
quite get to coaching so the difference
is on this presentation of your see me
live I like to talk with my hands and so
the valuation would be Jeff you spent
twenty-seven percent of your time with
your hands flying everywhere and it was
distracting so luckily I'm not on video
this one so you don't see the hands
flying around coaching would be Jeff I
noticed that you use your hands a lot
when you speak what would you like to do
to improve your performance around how
you use your hands the evaluation is
important I need to know where I stand
but if that's all I ever get from you is
evaluation after a while I feel beat
down so is your intent to build me up or
is your intent to tear me down when you
have coaching I moved from the
evaluation phase two okay now that we
know how you stand let's work on
building you up what can we do to help
you get stronger at this how can I help
you be better if you're working with
your leaders your question to your boss
or your leader could be okay I
appreciate the evaluation can you help
me think through some ways that I can
get better at this can we brainstorm
some ways
then put together a plan it's becoming a
partnership now and in that partnership
it allows me to trust you and allows us
to be able to form the kind of
relationship where i can get the
feedback get some evaluation but also to
move myself forward when you help me
improve my performance what's going to
happen is I'm going to trust you with
here's what I'd like to do here's why I
see myself in the lab and be able to
grow my skills which leads to again
greater collaboration or as the slide
says it is coaching is a collaboration
helped me refine what I'm doing and
change so question I have for you is are
you in the mode of almost a competition
with your employees are you to spot
where you're you're nervous that they
may take your job or you nervous that
they may be better at you and then and
some aspects of the role what I'd ask
you to do is suspend that you know what
you should be hiring people they're
smarter more talented than you why
because that will push you it will give
you the capacity to maybe work on the
next big thing the next process to put
in place the next idea maybe it's time
to bring lean into your lab so that you
can make the lab jump forward maybe it's
that partnership with the blood bank so
that you can better serve your patients
but if you are always trying to be the
smartest person in the room and view it
as a competition with your direct
reports very hard to build trust very
hard for you to be able to connect and
it will keep your folks from being able
to get engaged and motivated so start to
look and say as I'm getting ready to go
have a coaching and feedback
conversation with my direct reports am I
on the mode of coming and to give
criticism to correct or am I comment in
a place with my intent is yes I have
some feedback but I want to talk about
what's going right and I want to talk
about how do we help you get stronger
and better and here a couple things on
noticing there are two very different
ways of coming at it and the best
partnerships and the ways I trust you is
when
collaboration you give me feedback what
I'm doing well and you helped me grow my
skills so are you allowing your point to
learn are you letting them grow some of
you say well gosh f you know when do I
have time and does it have to be formal
do I have to go to an office and the
answer is no koshin doesn't have to be
formal you can absolutely pull up to the
bench and have a conversation some of
the best coaching is absolutely going to
happen there if you go all the way back
to Omar with me in in the desert there
you know his coaching right before I was
getting into the four-wheeler helped me
really calm down additionally him
showing how to move camels help me
understand when I was going with camel
later that day so some hands-on coaching
at the desk or at the bench absolutely a
wonderful thing to do so be willing to
pull the bench have a conversation what
I would ask you to think about though is
what is your intent and so as you are
coming to give that feedback again is
your intent to help build the person up
to be able to show them a few things
that if they do this a little better
they're going to be great are you also
taken some time to recognize them for a
job well done so again going backwards
do you have some ideas of the work that
they've done so you can celebrate it you
can also always have a coffee go for a
chat be able to maybe take a walk
outside kill two birds with one stone I
know many of you are in wellness
programs some of my best coaching
sessions are in 15 and 20 minute walks
because we're not always face to face it
makes it a little less intense so be
willing to think about coaching in new
and different places here's a tool that
I think will help you as you start the
conversations so this is called the
structural tension model a really good
book that highlights this model is
called the power of Ted and it's got
things like the dreaded drama triangle
in it and then Powerman dynamic I won't
go into that into detail today when
there's not enough time but one of the
models i do like fun it is the
structural tension model and basically
this is how you can start a coaching
session a team
eating a project review look at the top
what is the ideal state another way of
asking that is what is your desired
outcome what is it that we're hoping to
accomplish in our one-on-one together in
our time together in the team meeting in
the project review we then go down to
what's the current reality where are we
now relation to our desired outcome the
current reality could be cash for days
behind it could be you know we're only
at ninety-seven percent efficiency in
the lab and our goals 98.2 percent so
how are we going to get there what I
know is that we're really good at
current reality conversation we struggle
to start with the conversation around
what's been working well what is our
desired outcome so I challenge for you
would be can you start a coaching
session with what's our desired outcome
or team meeting with what's the desired
outcome for the team today instead of
comes with your own agenda so think
about this the reason the rubber bands
here let me explain it if you can just
picture a robe and being pulled between
my two thumbs the top thumb is the
desired outcome what's the ideal state
the bottom thumb is what is the current
reality so I can just picture that Ryan
and the team from Inc factor is drawn
away crazy some rubber bands and
wondering where I'm going but stay with
me so the top is the ideal state if I
let my thumb go on the bottom of the
robe and I get rid of current reality so
if i only have ideal state the challenge
with that is that that's all vision
that's all talk and we never get down to
the practical how are we going to do
this differently our lab how are we
going to get to the ninety-eight percent
quality measure that we're hoping for
now the flip that is we pull the rubber
band again but we get rid of the top
part we get rid of the desired outcomes
and we only have current reality this is
many of the labs made health care and
truthfully non-health core organizations
I work with we are all stuck in current
reality the downside of that is we only
do the transactional things so a lot of
our one-on-ones just deal with what's
happened in the last day two days we
never get to the transformational what
are the possibility what
the ideal state and so we really want
tension but we want to ease the tension
so the way to do that is ask these
questions so after we established
desired outcome current reality we then
asked the question what are our assets
resources what are our strengths what's
working well and that's not say there's
not barriers you can see down the
right-hand side what barriers may be
hindering us great well how do we
leverage our strength to overcome those
barriers and let's put some baby steps
in place so if you think about coaching
session we go from our desired outcome
so here's our current reality okay well
let's talk about how do we close that
gap whenever we done that well and how
do we change that so ultimately we're
able to have a conversation about baby
steps that's a coaching session it's
also really good at reinforcing
asset-based thinking how do we reinforce
our strength and our possibilities and
not get so hung up on some of our
challenges in the current reality so
again this is a great tool to try maybe
in your next one-on-one let's talk about
one-on-ones and some best practices so
you can see a bunch of bubbles here I'm
just going to walk through a few key
points here many of folks it that I
coach they say Jeff I really want to do
this but I don't know how well let's
start with the primary focus should be
on the ploy too often what happens is we
the leader come in and drive our own
agenda it's all about our desired
outcomes hey it's okay sometimes it
should be about us and sometimes you
need it to be about you but again
coaching is a collaboration and so if
you can come in and say okay you know
Erica what is your desired outcome from
our time together and she lifts off
three things and that's a great I've got
about two things I'd like to cover looks
like we've got a 24-hour time today what
do you want to start you can see that
you're given them some ownership of this
time it's a 50-50 partnership it's not
just coming to the boss and reporting
out it's now a partnership but make sure
that you understanding what the boy
hooks me get out of it because they've
been thinking about this one-on-one
maybe all week maybe all months and now
they're finally ready to come and talk
to you
and so if you come in with your own
agenda and don't ask any questions
they're going to walk out demotivate and
not engaged another thing to watch for
is make sure its regular best practices
is weekly now some of you have so many
direct reports that may not be practical
they may have to split up maybe your
supervisors or leads can help with some
of the regular one on once again it
doesn't always have to be scheduled in
an office it could be that that one on
one is by the bench and that may be the
best way that you can handle it but do
try to get some privacy from from time
to time to take on some deeper issues
watch rescheduling though because what
happens often is that you're busy an
important meeting comes up something
didn't go right overnight and next thing
you know you've just bumped three of
your one-on-ones well I may have been
waiting all week or two weeks waiting
for this conversation I'm so excited you
know I've told my in my case Beth my
wife that morning I'm going to have the
conversation my boss and so then you
bump me you can just see what's
happening to my motivation my engagement
so making sure that really try to honor
and don't reschedule next is be present
and this is really being present this
isn't checking your two different
smartphones this isn't looking back at
the data that's on your computer this
isn't seen who's in the hallway this is
putting those things down and really
have a one-on-one conversation if you're
looking to save time lots of you
schedule one-on-ones for an hour or 45
minutes but then you're distracted a
really great one-on-one can be 20
minutes of ten ten time with each person
and if you can put away the scratch
distractions it will be able to go
quickly so are you really present are
you really looking at them eye to eye
and having the conversation follow up
well seems pretty self explanatory but
you take a lot of notes and if you
commit to actions make sure you take
those actions again a trust breaker is I
left you with a couple things to do and
you didn't follow through I start to
wonder if you really care about me so if
you commit to doing something make sure
you do it this next tent in concept is
it should really be about 10 minutes of
them talking about
of you talking and maybe about 10
minutes of developmental so that
higher-level conversation and so if you
find yourself doing Apes of the talking
you're missing out on the core concept
of the one-on-one and if they're all
transactional and only business and
there's never what are your hopes and
dreams then after a while I wonder if
you really care about me do you really
care about where I'm in the organization
and so making sure you get to that
developmental conversation to help you
get to that developmental conversation
the next slide can help in that coaching
conversation so once you've established
goals and expectations and you've helped
me understand what to do you give me
some recognition you give me some
evaluation of how I've performed you
I've accepted feedback I've grown I've
developed I'm ready to really be in that
coaching relationship with you and so
this model is one that I use still in my
coaching practice it's called the iGrow
model the first is what's intention what
are both you and as a person coming into
the meeting hoping for so really for you
as a coach you should declare in your
mind before you get there what is your
intention what are you hoping to achieve
in your own mind then we should probably
have some sort of goal that we're
working on long-term so it may be I'm
working on getting better at budgeting
maybe I'm working on my influence and
how to get some my idea is accepted by
other parts of the lab or maybe if you
know i'm going to branch out and i have
a goal of growing and i'm going to need
a partner with the nurses in the
hospital and so being able to say what
is the goal that we're really talking
about the next step is reality so what's
been happening what am I seen here's the
progress I've made what our options that
given that reality where the options of
where the possibilities and then finally
what's next and the what's next is
what's the next action i'm going to take
let me just give you a concrete example
for my days at working in a healthcare
system for directors to be able to be a
director in our healthcare organization
you had to have a master's degree so i
came in knowing that the person I was
talking to did not have their master's
degree but they had a desire to move up
to the organs
so as I was sitting down to coach Joyce
the intention was how can I help her
achieve her goals and her goal was she
want to be a director in the next six
months we then went to the reality and
said well Joyce let's talk about that
you need to be having your masters
before you can be a director so it's six
months realistic tell me what you've
done to start the program well I've done
anything well then reality is we
probably can't get there because oh well
that really is no fun look coaching
isn't always easy I had to be honest
with her and tell her that's not going
to happen in six months so instead we
came up with some option saying what is
the best path for her and we were able
to find a night and weekend kind of
program she worked days where she was
going to be able to complete her
master's in 18 months her next step was
to go research and come back at our next
session be able say exactly what she had
done and which schools did she think
we're best going to fit her and then
could the system Eisen afford to pay for
that so that's an example that that
conversation really only took about 10
or 12 minutes but she left empowered
inspired and she walked away with the
work to do so it's a sample of how you
can use the iGrow method on the next
page I'm not going to go into a lot of
detail this is a leave behind but as
you're trying to discover the reality
these are just questions that you might
want to explore and so when you're
sitting down to that first one you might
be a little nervous about how to do the
session so what I want to do is just
leave you some questions my favorite
question probably how this is what are
you have tried already what actions what
difference did those actions may I want
to understand what they've tried I don't
want to assume anything I want to hear
their own it also helps me understand
how committed are they had they start to
try to do some things and are they
committed to their own growth and
development so for that person that is
not motivated doesn't seem to want to do
anything this is one of those tests a
litmus test to say well let's talk about
what you've tried what are your ideas if
they don't do anything between your
first conversation the second one give
them a second chance but notice and just
say here's what I noticed you seem to be
very excited but I don't see any action
for me to continue to give you the
coaching time and may they be able to
really help you you're going to take
responsibility for that if they continue
to not do that then you start to have to
ask the question are they right for the
organization because each person needs
to be getting better year over a year
you have to get better year over year
and they're not getting there you may
have to deliver a tough message saying
we got to get better so again as you're
sitting down to do your coaching session
for the first time there's some great
questions here another set of questions
that i really like can both be feedback
for yourself but feedback for the folks
you're coaching what do you need to
start doing and what do you need to stop
doing and so asking them how can I help
best supports you you can ask them what
do I need to start doing to support you
better what is it that need to stop
doing so there can be a more effective
leader and coach for you but you can
also ask them the same question what is
it they need to start doing so that they
can be the best person on your team that
they can be this builds off the lean you
can also obviously due to continue but
being able to sit down and have this
kind of conversation starts to build
that trust then if you're able to go and
actually do some research for them on
maybe the school their choice maybe it's
getting them exposed to another part of
the organization they're going to start
to buy into you and trust some of your
ideas the hardest part is often getting
started so the best suggestion i have is
sketch out your first coaching session
how do you get started well you're going
to have to practice so start with a
strong employee again sketch out what is
that you want to talk about maybe even
have the person have the structural
tension model i use that often in my
coaching sessions with leaders and with
teams and what I will do is I'll
officially give them the structural
tension model and say let's just walk
through this together
what is your desired outcome what do you
hope to get out of this time that we're
going to have together what do you hope
to get out of this year if you're
kicking off the performance review then
you can say great what's the current
reality so check in around do you
understand the expectations do you have
the tools to do your job do you know
what matters around here do you get
regular feedback what do you need me to
start doing and stop doing see how it
all starts come together then as they
are starting to think about that make
sure you highlight some of the strengths
you see and why you think they can do
what what their goal is that's the
positive recognition then when there's
barriers and they say well I can't get
to because maybe there's not funding for
this or there's not extra Y or Z saying
ok little sprain storm where are some
possibilities so again that helps them
show that they've got some ownership say
and influence here and then you can say
you can give ideas a coach to brainstorm
give ideas ultimately you want to go
with the idea that the employees the
most excited about though and not your
idea if you find yourself always given
advice then that's probably in the role
of advice giver and you're probably not
in coaching you should bother be in the
space where you're giving suggestions
asking questions but they choose the
course action and so that ultimately
they're the ones to declare this is my
next set of action steps and your wrap
up question should be what is it that
you need from me to help support you
teach your goals and when they hit the
goal have a great celebration so I was
just with one of my folks I coach down
at carolinas HealthCare and she finished
her master's this week so we had a
wonderful celebration on the phone but
more impressive was that her leader and
her team brought in balloons cake a
certificate and they bought her a charm
for a bracelet this was a huge
celebration for her it was something
she'd been working diligently for the
last two years and it all came together
with great coaching great partnership
between a great collaboration between
her and her leader and ultimately ended
up
in a wonderful celebration in our
coaching session yesterday she was just
bouncing with joy and you could just
feel it that can be the excitement of
coaching yes it's going to take some
practice start with a star employee it
will be easier they probably don't get
as much recognition as they deserve and
they'll be so excited as you care about
their career so again start with a
superstar then when you want to move on
to more challenging conversation
practice it with appear so that you're
ready for the challenging ones next and
the final five remain curious the reason
I say that is often we've been working
with people for a year 5 10 15 and
healthcare maybe 40 years but that
doesn't mean that they haven't changed
and they don't want to grow and develop
so don't put them in a box and say oh
that's the person that is always going
to be in this area they're always gonna
be a history check or they're always
going to be a phlebotomist no be curious
ask some questions give them some
feedback and say what is it that you're
hoping to accomplish and how can I help
you hit the goals that you're trying for
really get curious about what people
care about but also for you share your
own curiosity with your boss and say
here's what I want to learn here's how I
grow and I hope that part of it is that
use the iGrow model to have a coaching
conversation with some of the people on
your team and just be curious to see how
it works and maybe give me some feedback
on how it went so thank you for your
attention will now have some time for
questions I'm going to turn it back over
to lab roots so that we can address some
of your questions in just a moment thank
you
you